the right analysis of the data at the
right time can be very useful in a world
where data is being generated at an
alarming rate
at the moment apache spark is one of the
most amazing frameworks for handling big
data in real time and performing
analysis
hi everyone i am umbra suhil welcome to
simply lance youtube channel
we will discuss pi spark in this session
if you want more amazing tech related
videos do like subscribe and hit the
bell icon to stay tuned
let's get to the video to learn more
about pi spark without any further delay
we will begin the session with an
overview of apache spark
then we will proceed to our main topic
what is pi spark
and next we will discuss pi sparks key
features
moving forward we will understand the
rdd concept and need of pi spark
and then the difference between scala
and pi spark
after that we will understand pi spark's
data frame
and finally we will end this session by
discussing its use cases in the industry
in order to understand by spark and its
use in the big data world we must first
understand the party spark
so let's take a look at apache spark
apache spark is an open source cluster
computing framework that is used to
develop big data applications that can
perform fast analytics over large data
sets
spark is written in scala but it can
also be used from python using pysmark
it is very popular and one of the most
requested tools in the it industry
because it has inbuilt tools for rescue
and machine learning and streaming
so now that we understand apache spark
it will be easier for us to understand
pi spar so let's dive into it
pi spark is a python api to support
python with apache spark
python can easily be connected with the
purchase part using the pi spark
provided by folder library
when it comes to analyzing or working
with large data sets pi spot is
essential
pi spark is a python api to support
python with apache spa
python can easily be connected with
apache spark using the pi spark provided
by folger library when it comes to
analyzing or working with large data
sets pi spark is essential
pi spark is a mostly search tool among
data engineers because of its
functionality
so now that we understood about buy
spark now we shall move on to its
features
real time computing
pi spark focuses on in-memory processing
and offers real-time computing on
massive amounts of data
so the low latency is evident
the next feature which comes in is
support for several languages
scala java python and are just a few
programming languages with which the pi
spark framework is compatible
because of its interoperability it is
the best framework for processing large
datasets
the next feature we have is consistency
of disk and caching
the pi spark frameworks offer powerful
caching and reliable disk consistency
as we know time is money and to work
effectively we need powerful and fast
processing so the next amazing feature
of pi spark is rapid processing
with by spark we can process data
quickly roughly 100 times quicker in
memory and 10 times faster on the disk
so now we have come to the most
important feature of pi spark which is
effectiveness with rdd
working with rdd is made easier by the
dynamic typing of python programming
languages
if you are wondering what rdd is let me
give you a quick explanation of rdd
let's learn more about rdd
rdd stands for resilient distributed
data set
it is apache sparks primary data
structure
rdd in apache spark is an immutable
group of objects that computes on
several cluster nodes
resilient
with the use of rdd lineage graph the
system is resilient of fault tolerant
and is therefore able to recompute
missing or damaged partitions as a
result of node failure
now we have a better understanding of
pyspart and its features so let's
understand the need of pi spark
it's crucial to understand why and when
to use spark with python if you are
going to learn pi spark
here we will go over the basic factors
to consider while deciding between
python and scala for apache spark
programming
data science libraries
you don't have to bother about the
visuals or data science frameworks with
the python api
the r language's fundamental component
can readily convert it to python
the next factor which comes in is
readability of code
although internal modifications are
simple in the scala api
the python epa offers superior
readability
maintenance and familiarity with the
code
complexity in contrast to scala which
produces verbose output and is therefore
viewed as a complicated language
so the python api provides an accessible
simple and comprehensive interface
moving on to next factor
machine learning libraries
since python offers several libraries
based on machine learning approaches it
is popular for developing machine
learning algorithm because it makes the
process simpler
so now let's discuss the last factor on
our list ease of learning
python is simpler to learn and is known
for its simple syntax
in comparison to scala which has a
complex syntax and is difficult to learn
it is also extremely productive despite
having a basic syntax
if you are new to big data you have
probably heard of frameworks such as
spark
that technologies can be in python or
scala
how do you choose programming languages
to answer this question we must consider
various factors
let us figure out the answer to this
question by understanding the difference
between the two
firstly let's discuss the difference
between compiled versus interpreted
one of the major differences is that
python is an interpreted language
which makes it quite handy when coding
whereas scala requires you to compile
your code for it to be executed by the
java virtual machine
this process results in a file
containing bytecode
so the next difference is based on the
performance
spark offers two apis the high level one
where data frames and data sets are
found and the low level one which uses
resilient distributed data sets
scala offers superior performance with
rdds because python has an additional
communication overhead with a jvm
however python should not cause you any
performance issue
moving on to another difference that is
based on type safety
python has a dynamic typing
whereas a scalar has static typing
when using dynamic typing the type of
the variable you are defining is not
specified
your code becomes simpler as a result in
python the type of your variable can be
derived by writing its name and
assigning a value
now what's the difference when it comes
to a learning curve
it's typically easier to learn python
than scala if you are just a beginner in
any of the languages
python has a progressive learning curve
but once you get the hang of it you can
use the same simple syntax you started
with to do the advanced task
let's discuss the difference based on
the community support
python has a much larger user base than
scala which can help it gain support
as a result python benefits from more
comprehensive libraries devoted to task
complexity
scala does have robust support it is
still far beyond python
finally
let's discuss the last difference in our
list based on the project scale
python is a smart decision if you wish
to work on a smaller project with less
seasoned programmers
however scala is the ideal option for a
large project that requires numerous
resources and parallel processing
let's discuss the difference based on
community support
python has a much larger user base than
scala which can help it gain support
as a result python benefits from more
comprehensive libraries devoted to
various task complexity
scala does have robust support it is
still far beyond python
finally
let's discuss the last difference in our
list based on the project scale
python is a smart decision if you wish
to work on a smaller project with less
seasoned programmers however scala is
the ideal option for a large project
that requires numerous resource and
parallel processing
now let's learn about the data frame of
pi spark
a data frame in pi spark is a
distributed grouping of rows with name
columns
in simpler terms it is equivalent to an
excel sheet with column headers or a
table in a relational database
the spreadsheet is on single machine
whereas data frame is partitioned across
servers in data centers
it also has some features in common with
rdt
such as being immutable because we can
only build a data frame or rdd once
without being able to edit it
furthermore rdt and data frame are both
distributed in nature
large collection of organized or
semi-structured data can be processed
using data frames
petabytes of data can be handled using
data frame in apache spark data frame
supports a variety of data formats and
sources
for example python r scala and java all
have api support
after learning different topics about pi
spark in the session we have reached our
final topic which is pi sparks use in
industries let's take a look at it
apache spark is gaining popularity and
becoming more widely used by its users
from startups to multinationals
apache spark has been used to create
develop and innovate big data systems
here are various spark use examples for
particular industries that show how to
create and execute quick large data apps
ecommerce industry let's understand this
with an example
like shopify wanted to analyze the kinds
of goods its clients were selling in
order to find suitable retailers with
womb it may collaborate in order to grow
its business
its data warehousing infrastructure was
unable to resolve this issue since its
frequently timed out when processing
data mining queries on millions of
documents
shopify successfully developed a list of
stores for collaboration after
processing 67 million entries using
apache spark in a matter of minutes
the next use case of pi spark is in
healthcare industries
healthcare spark is used in genomic
sequencing
prior to spark organizing all the
chemicals compound with the jeans took
several weeks
with spark it only took a few hours now
my fitness all
the biggest health and fitness community
use cases of pi spark in industry
apache spark is gaining popularity and
becoming more widely used by its users
from startups to multinationals apache
spark is being used to create develop
and innovate big data systems
here are various spark use examples for
particular industries that show how to
create and execute quick large data
apps firstly we have e-commerce industry
let's understand with this an example
like shopify wanted to analyze the kinds
of code its clients were selling in
order to find suitable details before it
may collaborate in order to grow its
business
its data warehousing infrastructure was
unable to resolve this issue since it
frequently time out when processing data
mining queries on millions of documents
shopify successfully developed a list of
stores where collaboration after
processing 67 million entries using
apache spark in a matter of minutes
the next use case of pi spark is in
healthcare industries
spark is used in genomic sequencing
priority to spark organizing all the
chemical compounds with jeans took
several weeks
with spark it only tooks a few hours
only
myfitnesspal the biggest health and
fitness community uses spark to clean
user into data with the ultimate purpose
of identifying high quality food
products
the food calorie information of roughly
80 million individuals has been scanned
by myfitnesspal using spark
media and entertainment
with the help of apache spark pinterest
is able to identify patents and very
valuable user engagement data so that it
can quickly respond to emerging trends
by gaining a through understanding of
users online behavior
to offer online suggestion to its users
netflix leverages spark for real time
stream analysis
another best use of pi spark is in
software and information service
the spark developers have created data
breaks it is a platform that has been
tailored for the cloud to run spark and
ml apps on aws and azure
as well as a through training course
in order to grow the project and advance
they are working on spark
financial services provided finra assist
in gaining real time data insight from
billions of data occurrences
it can test things on actual market data
using apache spark
last but not the least pi spark is used
in travel industry as well
let's learn more about it
apache spark uses in the travel sector
is growing quickly
it facilitates consumer flawless
traveling planning by expectating
customized recommendation
by comparing numerous websites they may
also utilize it to advise tourists on
where to group hotels
spark is being used by tripadvisor a
popular travel website that assists
consumer in creating the ideal thing to
speed up its tailored client suggestions
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on pi spark i hope you found
this session both interesting and
exciting
if you have any questions about any of
the topics covered in this session or if
you need the resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below
and our team of experts will be pleased
to respond as soon as possible thank you
until next time this is umrah from
simply lantern signing off continue to
learn and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here